hello everyone I would like I was gonna
go into a bit but I don't have the
energy I don't got I've did it all on
stage yeah so who's got a question
anybody got a question were you what's
your name where you from sir I'm David
all the way from Israel really rule
you'll always have like a Star of David
and you're really you know you know
you're Yiddish yeah I love my polka yeah
you know what I just watch a lot of
Judge Judy you know she she I she uses
Yiddish on the show all the time and I
love it she uses she says the word Oh
I don't make this a whole ship the story
you know Turkish ICTA is it's like a
grandmother's tale it's just a long
drawn-out she or you can cut the Kashuk
the story hon I love Judge Judy
so my question is the show is really
doing well in in Israel you guys have it
on Netflix is that how you see it no no
we have it on cable or something
television wow that's amazing
any chance of getting you over to the
Holy Land you know we are actually we
were planning on a vacation there soon I
was there the last time in oh three my
luggage got stuck in another country so
I was there longer than I was supposed
to be and I got addicted to the Gilmore
Girls while I was in Israel and I didn't
get to go to Haifa but I loved Tel Aviv
we went to Jerusalem we went to the Dead
Sea we really got to see what Israel is
all about and I loved it thank you thank
you
who's got a question over here we're
gonna be here I'm roasting over here hey
mama hi Jeanne wolf how are you
a legend in the journalism world amazing
amazing
[Laughter]
well I was gonna say your
congratulations that your show
entertains people but it also as you wit
as you pointed out inspires them so the
idea is give them give them a message
with song and dance and feathers and
costumes yeah
is that is that what you do and and
where do you go from here well that's a
great question Jeanne and of course I
would expect nothing less than the
legend gee listen you know we started
out this show to celebrate the art of
drag and in doing so we brought along a
bunch of kids who had very backgrounds
and when you know we have challenges
that are fun and all that but these kids
bring their courage and their stories
and that's where the heart is there's an
interesting balance of entertainment and
of deep stories that really touch our
audience and I think that is why people
love us so much and I think is where we
got the Emmy well but you wouldn't say
as we were kidding around at the
beginning of the show we solved it that
message still needs to be told very
strongly oh yes there's so much that we
need to do in this country we're living
in a country that's very divided right
now I feel like our show adds a little
relief for the outsider
you know we celebrate people who dance
outside the box and those are my
favorite kind of people but those
stories need to be told and I think
there is value in those stories for
everyone not just drag queens or
superstar journalists like yourself
[Laughter]
but you look fabulous done as always
thank you Jeannie thank you anybody else
know he's got okay question over there
hi but she you or your feathers didn't
you yes
what's your name were you from Julia
pearpod from Tsinghua news of China oh
wow sand wait we're in China well it's
out of Beijing but it's all over China
500 million followers student is our
show appear in China not yes yeah you
never know you never know maybe this is
going to do it you know yeah what
congratulations not only near win but
also being the best trip crowd oh shucks
I bet you're just saying that look at
you're really doing some transformative
work with what you're doing on the show
I'd love to hear how you feel that
obviously it's it's impacting on the
LGBT community but also on the BLT
community too sorry yeah I love a BLT
honey if you love a BLT let's say hey
yes no we we do we do this for everybody
you know the truth is we all on this
planet have more things income and then
we have out of common is that a term
Michelle yeah now it is now it is but
you know really the truth is there's
only one of us here and these stories of
courage and a fabulousness and finding
your rhythm finding your frequency is
true for everybody in this room and
around the world well thanks for being
so aspiration thank you how do I say
thank you in Chinese [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] hey
[ __ ] [ __ ]
thank you thank you I'll be here all
week thank you last question in the
middle Oh money's in the middle where
are you from I'm Kathy I'm from BuzzFeed
news let's tweet news all right one of
my favorite segments on your show is
when you take the final Queens and you
ask them what they would tell their
younger selves and I don't have a photo
of you the way you typically show them
yeah but what would you tell young
RuPaul I would say young RuPaul don't
take life too seriously it's important
for you to understand that this is a
gift and it's important for you to
experience it don't take everything too
seriously and also don't co-op certain
negative ideas that other people have
because the ego wants to make everything
about oh they're attacking me mr. grant
but what it is is pay no attention to
all of the noise
follow your heart kiddo and you're gonna
do just fine you're gonna be snatching
trophies huh
[Music]
thank you guys so much graduates the
party